[Music]
Kendall it is so wonderful to be here
with you today thank you for joining me
thanks for having me I'm happy to be
here of course so you are a household
name everyone I think knows you you've
had a successful modeling career what
made you want to take the leap into
entrepreneurship I think I always felt a
really strong passion for it obviously I
come from a family of a bunch of
entrepreneurs so I think it felt really
natural for me I felt like I was in a
place in my modeling career as it was
like coming up on maybe n almost 10
years where I was just really ready for
something new and obviously I was a fan
as a consumer of tequila my mom and my
dad drank it all the time growing up and
then you know as I got older and I would
start drinking it I kind of was like
tasting different Tequilas loving
different Tequilas kind of just loving
the space again as a consumer not
knowing too much about the ins and outs
of it and found myself really passionate
about it I found partners and Founders
that also really wanted to be a part of
the space we then grew obviously we
didn't know much about Mak tequila so we
had to find the experts and our team
from there and my hand is pretty much in
every aspect of the
business a lot of firsttime Founders the
thing I hear the most often is like I
feel this imposter syndrome as a young
founder for you I feel like it's times
100 because you're in the public eye did
you ever feel like can I be this founder
am I going to be judged can I step into
this I think there's a lot of pressure
being one in the spotlight but then also
obviously running a business of your own
I'm a big affirmation person so I'm
always trying to talk up to myself and
talk kindly to myself and those
affirmations genuinely help me get
through those moments of impostor
syndrome how do you stand out and what
is the the Kendall brand that you're
trying to go for I feel like since I was
a kid I kind of always was a little
different I was always kind of sportier
and I just think that my path led me
here and I think that it feels really
fitting for me and I really enjoy
[Music]
it your family is really you know
synonymous with business how do you
navigate that Dynamic it's so funny you
ask cuz obviously my mom is my mom but
she's also my manager so we have moments
like when we're talking on the phone and
we're talking about business and we're
like maybe having a heated conversation
about something and then all of a sudden
she's like okay I love you how are you
feeling today and I'm like oh my God
like yeah you're my mom too like and
then we'll go talk about something else
like a bad day or whatever very mom
stuff mom daughter related things so we
have our moments but at the end of the
day I think we're really good at
compartmentalizing I think all of us are
we're all pretty pretty Pro not to toot
our horns but we're pretty Pro and I
think we get the separation between like
work fam time and business time and all
those things that makes sense you know
famous families they come and go but
none has really had the viral staying
power that your family has why do you
think that is I don't know I guess I
like there's something I mean I it's
like hard for me to answer that question
but we're wild and we're funny and we're
crazy but at the same time I think the
main energy behind it all is love and we
just like have so much love for each
other we stand by each other and I think
that maybe that's it I I I can't really
fully answer the question no that's a
good a good thought I guess that's what
I try and equate it to I guess 818 is
definitely your big business but the
other business I think is is you as
Kendall how do you decide which brands
and posts to to be sponsored of who do
you decide who to work with I find
myself to be a very intentional person
so any anytime I'm like working with a
brand or creating a brand or just doing
something that is genuinely me obviously
everything has to feel super authentic
to me but again super intentional like I
don't want to I don't want to do
anything that that doesn't align with my
vibes or my morals or my feelings and
things that really make me feel good and
make me feel like getting excited to
wake up in the morning and I and I had
to work to get to that place it wasn't
always that easy I can't just say yes
and no to everything I can't say no to a
lot of things espe especially 10 years
ago when I was starting you know it was
a lot of yeses and a lot of not only
feeling grateful to be in that position
but just feeling like you know I wanted
to build up my portfolio and my career
and all the things but now I think I
have the blessing of being able to say
okay does that align with me and I wake
up a really happy person because of
that if you could go back in time and
tell your younger self something before
keeping with Kardashians premiered what
would you say to the Kendall then what
advice would you have I think advice
would
be stop and smell the roses when you can
as cheesy as that sounds but I would
also tell her that like enjoy the ride
it's going to be like a beautiful
[Applause]
[Music]
one